ていません
[音楽]
こんなもちろん
練習したかのような拍手ありがとうございます
早速まあテレックス新富のトップバッターとしてお話を始めしたしてもらいたいと思い
ます
この896という数字を見てわかる人を何人かいらっしゃいますかこの数字が何があり
ますか
896という数字は
今後20年で消滅する自体の数だと言われています
つまり何かっていうともう地域が持続可能じゃなくなってきているというデータがある
ということですね
今日は宮崎県な色んな所から来ていらっしゃると思いますけれども
皆さんの
オニール例えば人たちの半分の自治体が消える可能性があると思っても過言ではないか
もしれません
こんな風な状況が今地域で起きているということです
今日のテーマでもありますこの笑顔とおかねぇ
ちょっと想像してみてください
皆さんどっちが大事ですか
彼らを
優勝もいるかもしれませんし
青いたいたいと
何歳ですか
いやいや楽しけりゃいいじゃんぞ
ヘル人もいるかもしれません
どっちが大事なのか今日はこんなテーマでちょっと話していきたいとおもいます
もう一つ最後にみなさんに聞いてみたいと思います
妬み僻み嫉妬足の引っ張り合い
奪い合う社会と
笑顔とお金のバランスがとれたずっ可能な社会
どっちの未来を
住みたいでしょうか
と想像しながら聴い
僕はもともとアメリカのシリコンバレーというところで働いていただきました
そこではすごくあのイノベーティブの場所で毎日のように産業が起きて毎日ように消え
ていく
それで facebook 安アップルやヤフーなんかがひしめき合って作業を作って
いた場所です
成婚バレーで5年働いた後日本に帰国しようと思って日本に帰国しました
海外から見た日本亭
朝にこんな感じなんですよね
今外国人観光客がすごく増えていますけれども今でもまさにこんな感じなのかもしれ
ません
僕自身もそう思ってます
フジヤマゲイシャ忍者天ぷら寿司
今もそんなキーワードが飛び交っていると思います
日本に帰ってきて
実際に現場弾どんな封印を着てたかっていうとこんな現状が起きてましょう
もしかしたら宮崎県の中にもこういう風景はあるかもしれません
シャッター通りん
耕作放棄地
あこがれの日本と帰ってきたらこんな風な風景が広がっていたんですね
そんな最中東日本大震災も起きて
へ
このままでは地域や街への愛やホコリがどんどん薄れていくんじゃないだろうか
地域は持続可能じゃなくなるんじゃないだろうかというような思いが自分の中に芽生え
始めます
だからこそ地域にはこの笑顔動画年
どっちかではなくて
どっちもバランスが取れた地域づくりが大事なんだという風に僕の中に芽生え始めまし
た
そして自分が学んできたビジネスの仕組みというものを地域づくりに取り入れることに
よって持続可能な地域づくりを実現しようというのが今の自分の取り組みであります
この持続可能な地域づくりでコンセプトとして大事にしているのはスモールイズ
ビューティフル
小さくて美しいということをテーマに活動しています
これは実は50年前にイギリスの経済学者が書いた本のタイトルなんですね
大量生産大量消費そんな時代はもう終わります
小さくても美しい持続可能なビジネスこそが今後のこっていくビジネスなんだ
そういうような本が出版されました車
そして50年たった今どうでしょうか
大量生産大量消費の時代ではなくなって一人ひとりが個性を生かしてありのままの自分
を探求するような生き方が今
夜中に起き始めていると多くは感じています
でもう一つこの睡眠いいというあの絵本がありますけれども
たった一つ一つは小さくても集合体になると大きな一つの魚に見える
これも地域の経済作りやビジネス作りにおいてすごく重要なポイントなんじゃないかな
と思っています
例えばこの新東3丁で1000万円の授業が100社生まれたらそれは1050億円の
経済規模になるわけですね
それも一つの地域づくりのポイントだなというふうに思っています
で僕自身もあの
宮崎県に来てクラウドファンディングを活用して地域づくりをやり始めました
もう2014年なので5年前になりますし今この会場にも支援をしてくださった方が
いいかもしれません
宮崎県の飫肥杉で使った製品を補助金を使わずにクラウドファンディングで
ニューヨークのギフトショーに守っていこうというプロジェクトを始めました
当時はクラウドファンディングまだ始まったばっかりでこの325万円という金額も
ものすごく高い金額ですごく注目を浴びることができましたそして国内だけではなく
海外からも支援が集まってまさにあの
補助金に頼らないようなプロジェクトが始まったということです
僕はその
飫肥杉のプロジェクトを体系化してもっとたくさんの人が使ってもらえるようにこの後
にシリコンバレー流地域づくりと名付けられるようなメソッドを一つ体系化しました
それがこの地域の魅力を発見して磨いて発信するというような
メソッドになります
この方法ですごく大事なのがたった一つあります
それは何かというとこの発見磨く発信というものを一連の流れでやっていくということ
なんです
皆さんをよく聞いたことあるかもしれませんがまず発見だけで終わる人も多いです
うちの地域にはいいもんがあるんだけどね
で終わっちゃうこと
そしてにで終わるパターンもあります
デザイナーさんにすごいかっこいいデザインを作ってもらいました
で終わるパターンもあります
そして
3番目で終わるパターンもあります
イベントを開催しました
それで綺麗な報告書をまとめて終わりというようなパターンがすごく地域の中ではある
んじゃないかなと思い
だけどこのシリコンバレル地域づくりというのはこのサイクルをぐるぐる google
回していこうと
そしてうまくいくまでやり遂げようということがこのメソッドのポイントだと思います
それ以外にも僕たちは自分たちの行動パターンみたいなものを一つ一つ分析をして
例えば八景の併存時は何をやるのか
磨くのフェーズの時は何をやるのかそして発信のフェーズの時は何をやるのかというの
を分析して体系化していきました
最終的にこのようにへ
時間が経てば経つほどビジネスモデルの精度が上がっていて地域がどんどんどんどん
良くなっていく
笑顔とお金のバランスのとれた地域づくりが実現していく確率を高めようと今も努力を
続けているところです
その結果として自分たち以外にも宮崎県も含めて全国各地でローカルヒーローが
どんどん誕生してきています
例えばみなさんも知っているかもしれませんが face くん
宮崎県日向市で
特産品柑橘であるヘベスを持続可能にしようということで
クラウドファンディングを活用して350万円を達成して今でも彼は
ヘベスを育てています
次に美郷町ここでは平均年齢約70歳のおばあちゃんたちと一緒にカフェを作りました
たった集まった金額は150万円ですけれども
カフェはちゃんと
街の中でもできて今でも継続して
つながっています
それ以外にも鹿児島県の離島の三島村の竹島という70す人口70人の島でもたけのこ
を開発して今でも彼はその事業を続けています
このように3人紹介しましたけど
ゼニーとエミーのバランスがとれた地域づくりというものを全国各地で今披露
やってきてるんじゃないかなというふうに思います
結果としてそれがシリコンバレー流地域づくりといって
日建 cm で紹介されたんですけれどもそんなこんなで活動しているなかで地域照射
固有財団この宮崎県新富町に2017年設立された鯉財団に声をかけてもらいました
恋財団自体も財政難少子高齢化を背景に持続可能な地域づくりを目指して設立された
財団です
でこの子有罪だーの中でもさっきの発見磨く発信する笑顔と
お金のバランスのとれた地域づくりを頃心がけてやっています
一つ目がこの一粒千円のライチを開発したということです
ライチ食べたことある人どれくらいいますか
数がそろってますね
糖度15度衣装平和思い出しながら聴いてください
ちょうど15度以上一つ50グラム以上のライチョウをブランド化して空港百貨店で
販売してまー今では県の特産品としても活動し始めているようなと
のライチです
何をやったかというとまず僕らが取り組んだのライチで
ライチの魅力ライチを作ってる人ら一度何なのかを研究して発見し始めました
一番大きなのがこの森哲也3度の出会いですね
生産者であるも冷徹屋さんと会って話をして
雷神の事を知って森さんの思いを知れば知るほどどんどんどんどんこのライチの魅力に
僕らもとりつかれていきました
そしてこのライチを打っていこうこのライチで浸透3町の特産として勝負していこうと
いう思いから
ライチの特産品の開発が始まりました
皆さんご存知かもしれませんが宮崎県と鹿児島で99%の国産のなバラ市が生産されて
いるんですね
そんなことそれを僕は知りませんでしただからこそ
じゃあたった9099%のシェアを持っているんであれば僕らはここで勝負することが
できるかもしれない
そういう発見があってこのプロジェクトスタートしました
次に魅惑です
ライチも僕たちが開始するまでもともと生産者さんが作って置いてありました
けれども僕らはこのライチを一つ1000円で販売するというふうに決めました糖度
15度以上50グラム以上の物を身と未来地とブランド化して販売することにしました
この販売するにおいても唯じゃあ一粒千円で出せば何とかなるわというような感じでは
なく
実際に最初はそんな物を売れるわけない
誰が買うんだとそんなことを言われたりもしました
それでもこのライチは絶対においしいし必ず売れる
じゃあどうやって伝えればいいのかどうやれば伝わるのかというものを売り方とか
パッケージの見せ方とか
デザインであるとか無理哲也さんも含めて何度も何度も濃い財団のメンバーで試行錯誤
繰り返しました
そしてこの磨くでやめるわけではなくて最後に発信です
発信するのもまずどこに売りに行っていいかわかりませんでした
まずどこに売りに行っていいかわからないからクーラーボックスを持って東京の銀座の
カフェを巡ったんですね
当然ですけどほとんどが門前払いです
そんなの入りません高すぎますでもたった一人だけ
パティシエの方がこんな美味しいライチ食べたことないって言ってくださいました
そして彼女が銀座コムサカフェというところのパティシエの形でぜひこれを取り扱い
たいということで1店舗目から始まりました
今でもこの銀座このさカフェでの取引は続いていて
店舗も拡大しています
番ホール
ライチケーキ銀座で売られている愛知ケーキに食らうと思いますか
ホールではだいたい1000円とか
各ても3,000円
けど今これは1万7000円で販売されています
それもたくさんの人に喜んでいただいて
すごく人気で売れ続けています
そういう形でライチを切り口に浸透3町では毎日新しいチャレンジが生まれてどんどん
どんどん
たくさんの人が集まってきているような現状です
大事にしていることは計画的に早くたくさん失敗する
このフェール faster の理論ですねとにかく早くたくさん失敗して成功に
近づいていこうというのを僕たちの大事なメソッドの一つにしています
そしてもう一つがプロトタイプ
とにかく作ってしまおうとこれはちょうどスタンフォード大学に去年行った時の会
写真なんですけれどもあの周りにある工具を使って何かをぱぱっと作って締めようと
いうような活動もやりました
もう一つ大事にしていることは仲間づくりです
よく聞かれるのがどうやってみんなを周りを巻き込むんですかっていうふうに聞かれる
んですけども
機構もうなんて思ったことはないんですね
とにかく自分たちがやってみて
そういうことであのつながりがある人たちと共感してくださる人たちと一緒に地域を
つくっていこう
ウィークタイズ理論というものがありますけれども例えばこういうところで出会った
弱いつながりそういう人たちと一緒に地域づくりをやっていこうというのを大事にして
います
何をやるかっていうよりも誰とやるかこれはすごく地域づくりにおいても大事なんじゃ
ないかなというふうに思います
僕自身も様々な組織でいろんな活動をしてきましたけれども
今この恋財団のメンバーとやっていくのが一番楽しくて充実しています
sdg ずの11番に住み続けられるまち創り様というのがありますけれども
この笑顔とお金の持続可能な地域づくりもここに当てはまるんじゃないかなというふう
に思います
笑顔とお金のバランスが取れていないと住み続けられるまち創りならないんじゃないか
と思っています
地域づくりにホームランはないですこれさえあれば上手く弾く
なんとかしてくださいそういうのはないです一個一個一個一個を小さな成功を
積み重ねることで初めて
ライチが増えたっっ新富町が変わってきた地域が笑顔とお金に満ち溢れてきた
そういうような結果が来るんじゃないかなというふうに思います
失敗もたくさんいます僕ら自身もものすごくたくさん失敗示してきました
軽度もやっぱり行動していかないと成長もないですし
成功もないと思っています
最後にみなさんにもう一度聴きたいと思います
どうでしょうか
笑顔透過音のバランスのとれた持続可能な社会がいいのか妬み僻み足の引っ張り合いが
いいのか
こっちの未来を進むということを決めることすらもチャレンジかもしれませんけれども
皆さんと一緒にこれからもいろんなチャレンジを続けていきたいなというふうに思い
ますありがとうございました
[拍手]